[Music]
on this Tuesday night pediatric flu
cases flooding Canadian hospitals the
wave of new infections and the calls to
get kids vaccinated we know influenza
can cause more severe illness in
children plus the challenges immigrant
doctors face working in Canada
government waste exposed the millions of
coveted vaccine doses thrown out and the
billions in overpaid benefits
the search for the remains of three
murdered indigenous women why Winnipeg
Police say they won't explore a landfill
site
and Squad goals we need a league of our
own getting the ball rolling on Canada's
first women's professional soccer league
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us the flu
epidemic is tightening its grip on
Canadians and health officials are
urging people to get vaccinated
including young children the wave of flu
viruses arrived early beating many
vaccination campaigns to the punch the
result has been a surge of sick children
canceled surgeries and traumatized
families in the last few weeks alone
there's been a dramatic spike in
pediatric hospitalizations because of
the flu children between the ages of two
and four and five and nine are
accounting for more than 50 percent of
cases and it is crushing hospitals that
were already operating at capacity as
Heather York's West reports the pressure
is so intense Alberta's Children's
Hospital is cutting services at some
outpatient clinics in order to redeploy
staff to deal with emergencies
sirens on blaring get her down to
Children's Hospital within about an hour
she was intubated there sedated and on a
ventilator four and a half year old Andy
Lloyd spent more than a week inside the
Alberta Children's Hospital ICU sick
with pneumonia caused by the flu she's
like lifeless it looks like almost she's
on life support so
um it was terrifying absolutely just
terrifying a triple demek of viruses
have been putting pressure on children's
hospitals for more than a month but
although RSV cases appear to be
stabilizing flu numbers are on the rise
we know much more than than covet
influenza can cause more severe illness
in children especially young children so
many kids are now in need of hospital
care that surgeries are being canceled
in Newfoundland Ontario Alberta and BC
the situation so serious in Calgary
where in addition to redeploying staff
from a pediatric respite program five
clinics for kids with kidney and other
serious illnesses are now having their
service levels reduced the more you know
flu vaccines that we can get into into
patients and family are children and
families I think could really help flu
shots have been available in most parts
of the country since late October and
it's well matched to the circulating
strain of influenza A but so far less
than 25 percent of the population has
rolled up their sleeve I think there is
fatigue in the population around
vaccination and I think unfortunately a
lot of the misinformation that spread
around the coveted vaccine has led to
some vaccine hesitancy or uncertainty in
the population if you can get the flu
shot I urge you to go and get the flu
shot Andy was finally discharged last
week after nearly two weeks in intensive
care a harrowing experience her mother
hopes they'll never have to live through
a game Heather your ex West Global News
Calgary
there is no easy solution to the crisis
in health care one thing that could help
ease the burden is licensing
internationally trained doctors BC is
expanding a program that makes that
easier and faster Ontario has a similar
plan in place in 2021 International
Medical graduates made up more than one
quarter of practicing physicians in
Ontario 34 percent of Alberta's
physician Workforce is made up of
International Medical grads that's well
above the national average and in BC 31
percent of doctors are internationally
trained nitugartia looks at how BC
intends to increase that
hello how are you Dr Navid puyan is a
physician who immigrated from Iran we
are servicing at least 200 patients per
day but he says he and others are
dealing with burnout and high overhead
costs largely because in BC unlike
Canadian medical graduates licensed
foreign trained doctors are forced to
areas with significant need in specific
predetermined clinics where they're
unable to negotiate their costs or
contracts in some ways essentially a
penalty for not being trained in Canada
they don't have much freedom to choose
their War conditions multiple examples
that the Immigrant physicians at the
same Clinic pays higher overhead
building a splits compared to the
counterpart Canadians and that's if they
can get licensed BC has announced a new
plan to Triple the number of foreign
trained doctors by 2024. that's why
we're taking action to get more
internationally trained doctors off the
sidelines it's being done through the
practice ready assessment Pro program an
evaluation process which is consistent
and comparable across the country and
used by all but three provinces Pei New
Brunswick and Ontario which is where Dr
Shafi Booyah trains hundreds of foreign
trained Physicians we need a fair
fairness in the system he believes the
key is to create equal opportunities for
internationally trained doctors once
they're licensed to practice in Canada
you have a license number but you are
not opportunity to call for residency
it's not so super rocket science we just
need to change the attitude because itps
are Canadian they are the taxpayer
there's a need to make Family Practice
more appealing to all medical graduates
who often grapple with issues around fee
structures and Clinic expenses according
to the head of the Alberta International
Medical graduates Association we're
having difficulty sometimes getting
Canadian medical graduates going into
Family Medicine which is where you know
there is a huge need if they have passed
the qualification exams and criteria
they should be treated the same as the
Canadian doctors need to Garcia Global
News Coquitlam BC
Canada's auditor general has gone
through the federal pandemic response
with a fine-tooth comb and turned up
lots of waste she broke down billions in
benefits that she calls overpayments
made by Ottawa and billions more that
still need serious scrutiny Mackenzie
gray reports
it was at the heart of the coveted
response benefits like the Serb and wage
subsidy quickly implemented to help
Canadians but it's that same speed the
auditor general says led to a key
problem billions of dollars have gone or
may have gone to ineligible recipients
of the over 210 billion in pandemic
supports Karen Hogan found the
government gave out over 4.6 billion to
people not eligible for benefits at all
and that at least 27.4 billion went to
individuals and employers that need to
be investigated further by the CRA
investigations the auditor general
doesn't think will materialize saying
Canadians shouldn't expect significant
unrecoverable amounts from those
billions and I'm just asking the
government to be clear with its
decisions and its approaches to
Canadians right now the legislation
would require them to follow up with
every individual and business that is
ineligible the minister in charge of the
CRA disagreeing with the auditor general
Diane Louboutin saying Hogan got her
calculations wrong and exaggerated her
figures wide scale enforcement from
louboutin's agency seems unlikely it
wouldn't be cost effective to pursue 100
of all potentially ineligible claims as
the CRA the conservatives who voted in
favor of creating programs like the Serb
and wage subsidy are linking these
payments to increased inflation wasteful
spending due to a lack of controls as
identified by the auditor general has
contributed to the cost of living crisis
we see today the Liberals say they have
no regrets for how they rolled out the
programs these benefits kept the economy
afloat at a time of unprecedented risk
they kept people out of poverty
addressed income inequality and
facilitated Canada's economic rebound
despite the ineligible payments Hogan
found the government met their
objectives by keeping Canadians afloat
saying the poverty rate would have
nearly doubled during the pandemic
without the benefits Donna okay
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you the
auditor general also looked into what
was the largest mass vaccination
campaign in Canadian history she says
the federal government did a good job
sourcing and distributing covid-19
vaccine doses quickly but failed to
prevent millions of shots being wasted
the report estimates 169 million vaccine
doses have been sourced at an average
cost of 30 dollars a shot that adds up
to about 5 billion dollars as of May
31st more than 30 million doses remained
in inventories across the country
another 50 million are deemed surplus of
those the auditor general says more than
13 million have already expired costing
Canadians 408 million dollars
Winnipeg police are defending their
decision not to search a landfill for
the remains of three murdered indigenous
women investigators suspect their bodies
may be there but say searching it is not
feasible for a number of reasons the
families of the victims don't accept
that
so what we're left with is the potential
task of searching for human remains
across a Four Acre Site
that was 40 feet in depth heavily
compacted with 9 000 tons of wet heavy
construction clay and distributed
throughout the site was 250 tons of
asbestos my mother didn't pass away with
the home so let's pay her the respect
that she deserves by finally giving her
one that's not a resting place at the
Prairie green landfill and for these
other women as well
Jeremy skibicki was initially charged
with first degree murder in the death of
Rebecca Contour her body was found last
week he was also charged in the deaths
of Morgan Harris Mercedes Myron and a
fourth woman known as Buffalo Woman
their bodies have yet to be recovered
and are believed to be in the prairie
green landfill
the loss of biodiversity is happening
faster now than at any time in modern
human history and that is the focus of
negotiators from 196 countries meeting
at a U.N conference in Montreal as Mike
Armstrong explains doubters say you only
have to look at past conferences for a
sign of what's to come Humanity seems
hell-bent on destruction it was with
that warning the United Nations
Secretary General opened this convention
that said work at cop 15 has begun over
the last few days delegates have held
early meetings day and night to set the
table but the convention's executive
secretary admits things aren't where
they should be some progress has been
made
but not so much as needed or expected
now this conference was supposed to be
held in China in 2020 the pandemic
pushed it back until it was eventually
moved to Montreal just this past June we
got an extra two years from the scourge
of covid let us not squander that the
goal of cop15 is to protect the world's
biodiversity human activities have
affected more than 97 percent of the
world's ecosystems that has left more
than a million species of animals and
plants threatened with Extinction a
major Target to turn that tide is what's
being called 30 by 30. it would have the
192 countries participating agree to
protect 30 percent of their territory by
2030 but when the world last met to iron
out a 10-year biodiversity plan it set
out 28 targets and globally none were
met organizers say this meeting brings
together more participants no not just
governments and the problem is more
pressing we didn't achieve our targets
before because we didn't give ourselves
the means to do it now there are
multiple planned protests around the
convention the first is set for
Wednesday morning it's being called an
assault on the convention center by a
group that says it's a coalition of
ecologists and anti-capitalists
There Was An Unexpected brief protest at
the conference Monday the prime
minister's opening remarks were
interrupted by an indigenous group
Justin Trudeau seemed to shake it off
saying cop 21 is about listening to all
voices Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal
access to abortion coming up Global News
investigates why some clinics in Ontario
are struggling to survive
since the U.S Supreme Court overturned
Roe versus Wade Canada's federal
government said Americans unable to
access an abortion there could come here
but there are issues in Canada too
though there are no laws Banning
abortion in Canada access to it varies
widely depending on where you live and
now a months-long investigation by
global news revealed some Ontario
clinics are struggling to stay open
Jasmine pesano reports this Ontario
abortion clinic manager is speaking
publicly for the first time I was
absolutely disgusted when I heard what
had happened in the U.S and he says it's
time for Canadians to talk about our own
abortion access I would love for us to
take steps forward in making sure that
these services are protected and women
will always have access to them Global
News agreed not to reveal Omar's last
name or where he works I've had friends
that live in the U.S call me immediately
after they heard what had happened and
they were begging me to give them
options they were telling me they're
like please what what should I do if I
become pregnant can I come can I come to
Canada
[Applause]
unlike in some U.S states there are no
laws in Canada Banning abortions but
equal access to abortion Services is not
guaranteed
a global news investigation in Ontario
found abortion centers that are
suffering from Financial neglect some
struggling to stay afloat in a system
where not all providers are treated
equally
in the early 1990s Ontario began funding
the overhead of a select few independent
surgical abortion clinics this improved
access and increased medical safety but
since then four more similar clinics
have opened and they receive no such
support from The Province Omar's is one
of them I don't really understand or
know how they've come to the conclusion
that these four clinics deserve funding
while other clinics don't abortions are
covered in Ontario with the province
reimbursing doctors for insured care but
Omar says that money is not enough to
cover all of the expenses needed to keep
his Clinic going we have to pay for
medication out of pocket we do pay for
rent we also do pay the salary of all
the nurses and counselors and
secretaries that we have working for us
on top of this there are Services his
Clinic offers that Ontario doesn't cover
including running a 24-hour patient
hotline so to maintain retain these
Services he relies on his patients to
pay a fee but only if they can a lot of
times we'd actually rather see it as a
donation with the specific demographic
that we deal with a lot of the patients
are not actually able to pay how much we
charge which is uh sixty dollars it
speaks to the commitment of those who
are providing the service because
they're doing it because they're meeting
a need they're doing it even though
they're being financially stretched to
to to to provide it Omar says his Clinic
has asked Ontario for funding twice
no response either time no just for the
the first time they said that our
requests would be forwarded to the
people that make these decisions and
then we never got any follow-up as a
result in an email Global News asked
Ontario's Ministry of Health for a
response to Omar's claims and why
clinics like his are excluded from its
funding Model A Ministry spokesperson
replied in a statement but never
answered these questions what would
happen to abortion access if clinics
like yours were forced to shut down oh
it'd be a huge blow if if we were forced
to shut down I cannot imagine where all
those patients would go if you're in a
situation where the clinics can no
longer be sustained you're putting
access really in jeopardy there are only
so many people Omar can help in a system
at risk of failure
Jasmine pizzano Global News Toronto
tomorrow we'll look at what changes are
coming to funding and operation of
Ontario's abortion clinics
back to the polls ahead what's at stake
in the runoff vote in the state of
Georgia
[Music]
former U.S president Donald Trump's
family real estate company has been
found guilty of 17 counts of tax fraud
and other Financial crimes the Trump
organization was convicted on all counts
after two days of jury deliberations in
New York Trump himself was not on trial
the prosecutors insisted he was fully
aware of the scheme
boaters in the state of Georgia are in
the midst of a runoff election that will
decide the last outstanding U.S Senate
race Trump's hand-picked candidate
Herschel Walker is facing Democratic
incumbent Rafael Warnock Farah NASA
reports on what's at stake
Georgia voters braving the rain and cold
to cast a ballot for the final contest
at the 2022 midterms after neither
candidate was able to win the state's
required 50 percent of the vote it is
such a privilege and an honor to get out
here and do my civic duty while the
Senate has already been won by the
Democrats this runoff has smashed early
voting records partly because of who is
running incumbent Raphael Warnock a
pastor George is better than Herschel
Walker amen and Walker a trump-picked
republican former football star with a
problematic past we're going out to win
this election so this election I'm
telling people to get out and vote
Herschel Walker will probably go down as
one of the worst Republican candidates
in in our party's history winning
Georgia isn't just about a single senate
seat here in Congress it's about an
outright majority a majority in
committees making it easier to confirm
judges and pass legislation Georgia is a
swing state and what happens in Georgia
is a real harbinger of what's going to
happen in the United States in the
coming years Georgia looks like the rest
of the United States in terms of its
demographic composition and in terms of
its political composition Professor Todd
belt says the race in the peach state
could change the way candidates are
picked by the Republicans we might be
seeing more candidates coming up through
the regular pipeline to challenge
Democrats in the future rather than
these one-off celebrity candidates Trump
was encouraged to stay away as he faces
the embarrassment of yet another
hand-picked candidate going down in
defeat foreignassur Global News
Washington
throwing the game next big plans for
women's professional soccer in Canada
[Music]
the men's World Cup is dominating sports
news right now but wait for it Canadian
women have big plans they already
dominate the game the Canadian women's
team won gold at the 2020 Olympics yet
Canadian women have to move abroad to
play professionally as microlay reports
that is about to change
it's the fastest growing sport in Canada
hands down yet the road for Canadian
girls to compete on a bigger stage has
always LED them abroad but that will
change in 2025 with the launch of a yet
to be named Canadian professional League
one day I want to go in the soccer
league the girls soccer league and make
it up there one day the Canadian League
has ambitious goals they want eight
teams and competitive salaries with
foreign leagues we're setting our sights
High because we don't think there's any
reason not to given our player pool
given the companies that are behind this
historically women's team sports have
proven to be a tough sell tennis and
golf routinely draw huge numbers but the
WNBA averaged 5700 fans per game last
season the us-based national women's
soccer league did a little better with 7
900. we've set projected attendance at 3
700 average per game we think that's
reasonable and we think it's
conservative joining the nwsl was
considered but the reported 50 million
dollar expansion fee is too high and
bottom line they want opportunities for
Canadian girls to be are the end of
yourselves in American League and
they're looking out for their American
players as they should be
um and that's why we need a league of
our own Christine Sinclair needs no
introduction she's the top International
scorer of all time man or woman her
brand may be established but she argues
other Canadian players have lost out on
marketing opportunities by virtue of not
playing at home every time any of us are
back in Canada the draw is there people
want to hear from you the kids want to
see you companies want to engage with
you
but if you're living in England
how many days can you commit to being in
Canada realistically uh throughout the
course of a year
one of these girls could be the next
Christine Sinclair but without the
opportunity we'll never know microlight
Global News Toronto
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's here Canada
is the work of the BC professional
firefighters burn fonden Vancouver
Stanley Park always stunning we'd love
to see your festive Canada photos please
email them to us and thanks for watching
bye-bye
[Music]